the jurgen experience
star was born was
something that when i first read it
i called her and i said i read this
thing show you schmuck it's been made
three times before and she hung up the
phone on me that was 1976 with wow and
that's when i met elvis
i went through your imdb holy [ __ ] of
you produced a lot of movies yeah
a lot of marijuana man
a lot of getting [ __ ] up jack
you made so many movies yeah over a
hundred that's incredible
that's incredible yeah because i always
was a storyteller
and as a kid i was i didn't always tell
the truth but they were my stories my
life became my story
my stories became my life the things
that i'm doing today
are things that i said i would do i
wanted to be i wanted i was in love with
ali i made ali the life story of i was
in love with presley i wanted him to be
in starsborne we flew up to vegas
and we met with him
and uh he was so fat he couldn't sit in
a chair he was about a hundred pounds
overweight wow and he said i got a
problem man i got a problem i said
what's your problem he said i'm having a
fight with my girlfriend
and i said what does that mean she says
well she's flying in my 747
for two hours i haven't decided whether
let her land or not
so yeah so i've been lucky i've been a
really blessed lucky guy did you meet
elvis when he was doing karate uh yeah
so that was when he was ed parker no no
no no no i met him once
when he was
uh really fat
and uh
colonel parker called me and said he
wants to do the movie
but you can't be a part of it so i
called because i was a producer i
created i wrote it i i there was my
thing man i was obsessed with this movie
and uh the love story was me and barbara
we copied it
and barbara said [ __ ] him i said [ __ ]
you and so he didn't do it and then
later after the movie priscilla presley
called me
and said to me i gotta tell you
he wanted to see it on opening day and
he did and he cried that he didn't do it
because i would have got to the other
side elvis
i would have got to the pain
i would have got to the feelings i would
have got past the other thing
it would have been gigantic because i
saw that in him i could feel the pain in
him
so when when you met him was towards the
end then like this time towards the end
did you watch the film the new one the
new elvis movie fantastic it's amazing
right yes because they did it
differently yeah they did a completely
different take it was amazing the way
the just the way it was edited and put
together with all the you know the
things in between the scenes it was
incredible yeah it was so good
but it's like that story is such a
unique story because there had never
been a person like him before that was
that famous ever ever he still gives me
chills man michael jackson was like the
next one right he's never been someone
like him either michael jackson
and i
uh um
i went to him
and i when i was doing star wars born i
mean uh batman
and i had prince to do the music
and i wanted michael to do the warring
theme so it was like a fight
so michael jackson plays no thank you
michael jackson plays
uh you know batman
the guy and prince plays the joker
jack nicholson but
michael backed out we became friends he
took me to his house he showed me
thriller
and he said why so why show him this is
because you did american war with london
and i copied you to do thriller
wow
you